did you hear about dan bongino saying
that he would he's going to he's going
to quit his program cumulus right
cumulus over their vaccine mandate yes
curious what you think about that well
so the context just real quick is dan
van gino's got like his show is on over
300 different radio networks right he's
signed to uh with a company called
westwood one which is part of the
cumulus radio network and he said if
that company cumulus wants to have a
vaccine mandate then i will quit this
show unless they stop you can either
have the vaccine medic or you can have
me now i've got a lot of thoughts now
but i'm curious what you think
and dan by the way and one thing i did
see with that one wrinkle was that he is
personally vaccinated because he had uh
cancer issues so he was someone uh who
obviously is immunocompromised i have a
friend um who had throat cancer is just
getting over that and he's like
he needs to wear a mask all the time
right and it makes sense right because
he's immunocompromised you know as far
as dan i think that's amazing i think
that's fantastic i you know i was one of
the guys that i got
freedom flu going worldwide and it was
the number one trend on twitter and this
is between southwest it wasn't just the
weather
um and delta and the rest of the people
in the military and everything that's
going forward is
you need to stand up against medical
tyranny and i think that's what he's
doing i think he's looking at it from a
perspective of i don't want to live in a
country where we mandate things like
this when it look
if
i saw people saying this when i was
tweeting about it someone had commented
and they said well what if kovid was 10
times more deadly right and what if this
and i said well what if what you know i
live in reality where do you live right
like yeah what if it made people turn
into vampires yeah
what if it whatever right it but the
point is it doesn't but for some reason
you people have deluded yourselves into
thinking that covet is something that
it's not i i have a really simple answer
to a lot of the the the promenade people
they're like
what about all the other vaccines that
we mandate like mmr and i'm like i've
never been mandated to get vaccinated to
go to the store to buy a slice of pizza
right no one has right so we're not
something entirely different for example
right when i was in the military right
so when you first join you go through
boot camp um you go through you go down
what's called vaccine alley right in
vaccine alley it's like left arm right
arm left arm right and they tell you
what it is they're like oh this is the
we don't remember like this is this one
this is that one this is this one that's
that one you're just left arm right arm
left and right and the last one well it
goes somewhere else but yeah
and then and then when i went to
guantanamo um because we were with the
afghan detainees and tuberculosis is
still an issue in afghanistan i got the
tuberculosis shot and so those are all
vaccines that have been going around
forever and
you know every year we're also mandated
to get the flu shot when i was still in
and every time when they gave me the
active culture that's the one that's
like this the mist they kind of missed
it in your nose every time i got that i
was sick and then i would i would like
try to talk to the guy i'd be like you
know like the hm2 the hm3
hey man you know can i get that shot
because you know i really don't want
that missed because i know it's going to
make me sick when i have to call out
again there's like sorry man you can't
do it right but
again these are all vaccines and shots
that have been around for a long time so
i was i was thinking about dan bongino's
show and i'm like isn't it better though
that he's on the networks of these
companies speaking out against it
you know if there are people at these
companies who can't speak out or they're
scared to i'm it's still better that
he's appearing on their radio network at
least giving them some argument more
importantly i was like
if that's going to take away air time
from the radio network
and then result in people working for
danbon gino instead who don't have to
live under that mandate you have more
jobs with no mandate as opposed to the
radio network producing their own shows
and then having the mandate you know
what i mean
so like syndicating a show is better
than them running their own because that
would make more mandate because at least
you have a voice
well well i mean like
let's say let's say are you saying are
you saying take up space
yeah yeah yeah well listen cumulus says
we've got a 10 p.m slot let's hire this
radio house to do a show for us
okay he's got to be meant it's a it's a
mandate for vaccines for him and all of
his staff now you've got 10 people who
are being faced the vaccine mandate or
they say why don't we syndicate someone
else's show now those 10 people find a
job with dan bangino with no mandate you
see what i'm saying right so maybe it's
actually better to occupy the space from
these companies so that
it weakens across the board the amount
of people who are under a vaccine
mandate
i really and honestly though i've seen
dan do this like dan's someone who quit
twitter as well so that reminds me of
right so he quit twitter and i believe
was when he was going to parlor and so
now he'll still do the um the bondino
report on twitter but he won't
personally go on twitter anymore and you
know i just i've seen and i mean i know
dan
um and yeah fox came back so fox came
back on twitter and i you know i know
dan we talk a little bit on the back end
um i think he's a great guy i totally
get it but i i know he's taken stands
like this before so it didn't surprise
me when i saw something like that to say
that in his mind it's like i can't
support something morally right if i
have a moral problem with this then i
can't go along with it so i think that's
where he's coming from
yeah i mean it's it's also very easy to
fake a lot of this and to comply and
people are just not doing it based on
principles based on morals we had kyrie
irving we have so many other people we
have firefighters we have police
officers we have nurses we have medical
professionals saying hey this is a big
line here and i think we're witnessing
some of the biggest protests ever
especially when it comes to
how many of them are happening all over
the world how significant they are how
many people are pushing back against a
lot of this and it's just adding a lot
of strangeness to the fact that the
mainstream media doesn't even
acknowledge that there's another side
that there's another debate that there's
a whole bunch of other people standing
up and saying no this is not okay we're
not going to go along with this so um i
mean i mean there's so many last couple
times the last couple times i flew um
you know i just mentioned i was in
denver and
phoenix um
almost at every airport i was going to
there was only one tsa checkpoint
that the whole thing had been wound down
because labor shortage a lot of tsa
agents are also not complying with
exactly the facts mandate
i think it's over forty percent yeah
that that haven't and doesn't happen
yeah yeah so that's forty percent of the
workforce that's a significant workforce
of already you know a big bureaucratic
agency that doesn't do their job well
now they're going to do it a lot worse
well tsa i mean to begin with tsa is
largely theater exactly it's all
security theater it's not when i was in
i can tell you stories about working at
o'hare you know we used to um
we used to um we would send people in
with like you know for when it was in
the navy and it was all it would all be
you know set up obviously you would get
someone like um you know a dummy ticket
and then you'd give them a device um one
that was designed to appear to be like
an ied and of course this was all set up
under departmental insecurity whatever
media matters and we would send them
through and something like 90 of the
time they would go through higher it was
like ninety five or nine yeah
i'm just saying the ones that i've done
so so and then the people i'd go with
would have to sit down with the tsa
agent as they're pulled into secondary
screening and they'd show them the
device and it would be like you know a
bag of doritos and then a soda can
inside of it and then just like all
these electronics and crazy stuff on the
inside and they're like you just let
this through i used to work for uh
american eagle airlines this is a long
time ago and back when i was like 18.
and
at o'hare
they they said if you're driving into
the employee lot you just pull up to a
booth hand them your id card they swipe
it hand it back to you and you drive in
there's no frisk there's no search then
you get out of your car you get on the
bus the bus takes you to the terminal
this is pre or post 9 11.
this is very much post 9 11 based yeah
yeah
not that old that wasn't old enough to
be working in the night no no i'm just
yeah i'm just doing the number but um
if you took the train
to work you had to go through security
they said if you're taking the train
through work for if you're taking the
train to work or the bus or you're
getting a ride here you got to go
through normal security like everybody
else and then come down to your zone
room and then i was like
there's there are these doors all over
o'hare that have keypads and as an
employee at the airport you get a card
that you swipe and punch in a code and
it opens these doors okay so when you
want to go from like if you want to eat
food you got to go up to the terminal
you got to go to where the restaurants
are yeah so you you open the door when
you're coming back to work you got to
swipe your car punch it that lets you on
the runway basically because we go out
on the tarmac and my favorite thing was
i i don't know if they still do this
probably at o'hare
where the baggage uh uh uh conveyors are
there's doors that go right to the back
room and and a lot of people who do who
work the ramp that's what's called
working ramp will drop bags off there
and some people work in the back room so
i'd be like so you want me to go
upstairs go through security then go
downstairs go through a similar door
into the bedroom instead of just walking
right in the front door swiping my card
and walking in the back room well well
then you wouldn't be going through
security what's the point of security if
this door is here and anybody can walk
through it you can just walk right
through it technically what
you needed a security card to walk right
through it what kind of security or
background check would there be for an
employee though
well so i went through a federal
background check i got fingerprinted and
they gave me then they gave me the id
card so
they still want you to go through
standard security which makes no sense
because if you if you own a car you
don't have to do it and that's when you
can actually carry stuff in your car
that's you know what are you going to
carry you're walking into the airport
with just your backpack but then if
you're downstairs and in the in the
baggage collection area there's a door
you just walk right over to and you
swipe it and you walk right into your
workplace but they they tell you you're
not supposed to do that i'm like dude i
don't care what you think someone is
supposed to do you have no security if
that door exists for employees don't act
like you have a spot like you which
employees must go through security like
everybody else no they don't that's just
ridiculous but if you bring a bottle of
water on board oh they're gonna be on
you like white on rice my favorite thing
about the uh the bottle of water thing
is so right they make you put the water
in the containers right that are all
right there so oh this is too much
liquid so you have to throw on the
garbage you're sure i'm going with this
so throw it in your garbage so the next
person comes up and they say that okay
now you throw your over three ounces in
the garbage so theoretically
this is all like liquid nitrogen and all
these explosives right so you're
creating right again theoretically wow
an entire yeah you get it an entire
country if you have a bottle of liquid
nitrogen full of you know full of
explosives that's just sitting right
there
and that's that's the way that you guys
consider to no obviously that's not true
i remember one time though i was flying
with a uh with a shotgun that i'd
purchased in arizona i was flying home
with it and you know i called tsa ahead
i'd called the airline ahead and said
hey i'm bringing this it's in the case
it's compliant it's got the locks it's
got everything so i bring it up
and it was american airlines and i
remember the
um the check-in you know the check-in
lady was there and she goes well i need
to inspect this i say okay you know i'm
gonna unlock it and here's you and she
goes all right now you need to take it
out and i look at her
and i'm like
let me just hold on before before i
respond to you let me just repeat what
you said you want me to take my shotgun
out right here in the middle of the
airport
i was like ma'am i'm not going to do
that and then she looks at me and she's
like
oh well maybe i could just open it in
the case and take a look at it
yeah maybe you can do that ma'am yeah
you